hello everyone welcome to this video on
the top highest paid job roles in
machine learning by simply learn to stay
updated with our content make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn the job opportunities in
machine learning are as wide ranging and
abundant as the technology applications
from self-driving cars to online
shopping speech recognition and face
recognition there's virtually no
significant area of Modern Life that
hasn't experienced a transformation due
to the work of machine learning
Engineers who build them if you're
aiming to work in the field that offers
impressive pay and benefits along with
excellent job satisfaction machine
learning is for you moving forward we'll
cover some top machine learning jobs
showing upward machine learning salary
Trends the list covers machine learning
salaries by job rooll and geography on
the that note if you're an aspiring AIML
engineer there's no better time to train
yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you're looking for a
course that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our celtech in partnership
with IBM this Ai and machine learning
boot camp in collaboration with celtech
will help you advance your career as an
AI nml specialist this a ml boot camp
includ live classes delivered by
industry experts Hands-On Labs industry
relevant projects and master classes by
celtech professors key features of this
amazing machine learning course includes
that is earn up to 22 cus from Kelch
ctme the next is online convocation by
keltech ctme program director then we
have simply learned career services that
help you get noticed by top hiring
companies and you will earn a boot camp
certificate from the celtech ctme and
the industry relevant Capstone project
in three domains celex ctm is circle
membership 25 plus Hands-On projects
across industry verticals with
integrated Labs so why wait join now
seats are filling fast find the course
link mentioned in the description box
and pin comand so without any further
Ado let's get started so number one on
the list is AI research scientist AI
research scientist dedicates their
efforts to creating Innovative models
and algorithms within the realm of
machine learning their work involves
pioneering research and exploring
emerging Concepts and Technologies this
role Demands a strong grasp of
mathematics statistics and computer
science along with Proficiency in
programming languages like python or R
exceptional problem solving abilities
are also crucial AI research scientists
typically command an average yearly
salary of $91,000 in the United States
and in India an average annual yearly
salary is around 9 lakhs per an
moving forward let's see who wants more
than AI research scientist and now
number two on the list is NLP engineer a
natural language processing engineer is
a professional responsible for crafting
and constructing computer systems that
can process assess and produce humanlike
language NLP branches out into numerous
captivating domains including semantic
analysis sentiment analysis face
recognition machine translation and
speech recognition the reach of an LP
extends across a diverse spectrum of
applications notably featuring virtual
assistants chat boards sentiment
analysis customer service interactions
and natural language translation the
task of NLP Engineers involves erecting
these Innovative applications and
seamlessly embedding them into existing
Frameworks and now the average salary
for an NLP engineer is
$115,000 in the US and in India the
average annual salary for NLP Engineers
is 10 lakhs perom moving forward let's
see who owns more than NLP and genium
the next is data scientist a data
scientist harness statistical and
machine learning methodologies to derive
valuable insights from extensive data
sets their duties Encompass formulating
experimental designs crafting predictive
models and conveying their Revelations
to relevant parties vital proficiency
involve adeptness in programming
languages like python NR a firm
grounding in statistics and a Mastery of
data visualization given the substantial
demand for their skills data scientist
command an average yearly salary of
$128,000 in us and in India average
yearly salary is 14 LHS perom moving
forward let's see who wants more than AI
research scientist NLP engineer and data
scientist the next is machine learning
engineer a machine learning engineer
conceptualizes and constructs models and
Frameworks tailored for machine learning
purposes essential proficiencies and
compass adeptness in programming
languages like python NR a grasp of
statistics and Mathematics and hands-on
experience in data manipulation their
dut is span handling substantial data
sets cooperating with vested parties and
Engineering Systems that are both
scalable and maintainable the average
annual income for machine learning
Engineers is
$140,000 in the US and in India it is 20
lakhs perom and the last we have deep
learning engineer de planning Engineers
construct and formulate intricate neural
networks for tasks like image
recognition and natural language
processing profound familiarity with
deep learning Frameworks like tensor
flow and pytorch alongside adeptness in
programming languages such as python is
imperative Proficiency in advanced
mathematics and optimization techniques
is also indispensable their duties
Encompass the creation and training of
deep learning models refining model
efficiency and meticulous parameter
adjustments on average deep learning
Engineers earn an annual salary of
$158,000 in the US and in India average
annual salary is 25 lakhs perom it's
important to note that salaries can vary
significantly based on location and
other factors for instance job
opportunities and compensation are
higher in Tech hubs like Silicon Valley
New York City and other major tech
centers worldwide to get the most
upto-date information on salaries and
job Trends in the machine learning field
check job boards industry reports and
salary surveys specific to your region
and Industry also check our postgraduate
program in AI nml in partnership with P
University and in collaboration with IBM
to upskill yourself in this thrilling
field of machine learning and don't
forget to check the course link from the
description box below and with that we
have come to the end of this session on
top highest paid job roles in machine
learning I hope you found it valuable
and entertaining please ask any
questions about the topics covered in
this video in the comment section below
our experts will assist you in
addressing your problems thank you for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply YouTube channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to ner up and get certified click
here